this morning it's joe biden's turn to go
to kenosha wisconsin where a police
officer shot
jacob blake seven times last month the
democratic nominee's visit comes two
days after president trump toured the
city
and after a new poll found the president
trailing
in that crucial state local officials
asked both candidates to stay away from
kenosha
as ed o'keefe reports biden plans to
meet with blake's relatives
even after they joined the request to
stay away
we got to heal we got to put things
together former vice president joe biden
says he's visiting kenosha
to start a dialogue he told reporters on
wednesday that the officer responsible
for shooting jacob blake
should at a minimum be charged i think
we should
let the judiciary system
work its way president trump in north
carolina to commemorate the end of world
war ii
has said little about the shooting in
kenosha instead
focusing on violence nationwide american
warriors did not defeat fascism and
oppression overseas only to watch
our freedoms be trampled by violent mobs
here at home
but attorney general bill barr did talk
about blake's shooting
he was in the midst of committing a
felony and he was armed
barr provided no evidence blake told
police he had a knife in his possession
but it's unclear whether he ever held it
police recovered a knife from his car
but no other weapons barr also pushed
back on those who say systemic racism is
a problem in the criminal justice system
to me the word systemic means that it
that it's
built into the institution and i don't
think that's true
meanwhile the president remains
optimistic about the pandemic
i think we're rounding the turn on this
china virus
but biden disagrees and is pushing the
trump administration to direct
billions in federal disaster aid to buy
masks and cleaning supplies
so schools can reopen safely this is
emergency mr president
this is an emergency and donald trump
and his fema
should treat it as one but he admitted
that some of his ideas like a
three-month mask mandate that he
proposed
last month could be difficult to enforce
you had suggested there would be some
kind of a federal mandate about masks
and now you're saying
no no no no here's you can't do things
the constitution doesn't allow you the
power to do
what i would be doing is putting as much
pressure as i could
on every governor every senator i'm
excited
every uh mayor every county executive
every local official
and everyone in business
so biden heads to wisconsin today armed
with data from a new fox news poll that
shows him up eight points over the
president
he's also leading in battleground states
arizona and north carolina and notably
in wisconsin in that fox poll
on the question of which candidate is
better equipped to deal with criminal
justice and policing issues
biden leads the president gail all right
ed 60 days and counting
thank you